c'est le plus grand remaniement
ministériel de jaillir ball sonar haut
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir il ya un
peu plus de deux ans le président
brésilien a décidé de se séparer d'un
tiers de son gouvernement
six changements de ministres à des
portefeuilles clefs comme ceux de la
justice de la défense ou encore des
affaires étrangères le seul départ
attendu depuis deux semaines était celui
du chef de la diplomatie
ernesto alors aux mises en cause dans le
fiasco de la politique anti kovy 19 du
brésil autre poids lourd a quitté le
gouvernement le ministre de la défense
fernando azevedo et silva une démission
qui a créé la surprise dans le pays est
pris de court les observateurs un
remaniement marqué aussi par l'arrivée
de flavia arruda au secrétariat de la
présidence
en nommant cette députée du centre euros
le président veut montrer son
rapprochement avec le groupe informel de
parlementaires centristes qui monnaient
leur soutien en échange de postes
importants
avec ce changement dans les hautes
sphères jaillir ball sonar au fortement
critiqué pour sa gestion de la pandémie
tente un recentrage le président
brésilien fait face à des pressions
grandissantes pour répondre avec plus de
sérieux à la crise sanitaire
le brésil a dépassé les 314 milles morts
du courant d'un virus en un an
pays le plus endeuillé au monde après
les états unis